Despite being the kind of nailbiter we've
come to expect from The Walking Dead,
the series finale didn't go down well
with everyone. Here are the moments
from the final episode that upset people the most.
Near the end of the Commonwealth storyline,
Daryl does something that fans of TV shows
either love or hate — he says the name
of the show. In a brief, dramatic – well,
as dramatic as Daryl ever gets – speech to Pamela
and the Commonwealth soldiers, he gruffly says,
"We ain't the walking dead."
Then he boss-walks toward the
gate without another thought.
It's a cool moment, and a lot of fans ate it up.
Twitter ran rampant with reactions to the line,
a lot of which were positive. However,
there were plenty of tweets making fun
of the title drop, and some people
flat out hated it. One user tweeted,
It's a clear callback to Rick Grimes in Season 5:
"We are the walking dead."
Easter egg or not, Norman
Reedus revealed to Vanity
Fair that he had to be talked into it. He said:
After 12 years of The Walking Dead killing off
main characters and practically being driven by
death, it's widely accepted that no one is safe.
We've seen beloved characters take their leave,
including a number of children.
One issue with the finale is that
spin-offs have already been announced, so
a number of the survivors — like Daryl,
Maggie, and Negan — were at no
real risk of being killed off.
While all fans have characters they root for,
most were expecting to see a
bit more bloodshed. On Reddit,
the general consensus seems to be that the finale
lacked any meaningful deaths. One user wrote:
Another bone fans have to pick with the
finale was how it handled the lost members
of Magna's group. The writers brought Luke
and Jules back seemingly out of nowhere,
just to abruptly kill Jules and
kick off the finale by killing Luke.
There's no denying that the heavily emotional
death of Luke, still reeling over the loss of his
girlfriend and in pain from the loss of his leg,
started the episode out with a bang that seemed
to promise a finale that takes no prisoners. Luke
would turn out to be one of the only survivors to
die, though, which makes his sudden return
and abrupt exit feel somewhat sacrificial.
Many fans saw Luke's death as nothing
more than a way to squeeze some gore
in without killing off a main
character. One commenter wrote:
While another said that,
The series finale is full of callbacks, including
the way Judith wakes up in a hospital bed. This
is how the series began, with her father waking
up in a deserted hospital back in the first-ever
episode. While the nostalgic parallel was
nice, many fans think that since the series
opened with Rick, it should have closed
on him, too. It's true that a lot of fans
on Reddit have said that Rick was present
in more of the finale than they expected,
which is a great thing. However, there are
those who wanted it handled differently.
One user wrote:
Others thought the Rick scenes were a
letdown. According to a second user,
Fans missed Michonne after Danai Gurira exited
The Walking Dead following Season 10. Many
people wanted and expected her to pop up in
the finale to help her fellow survivors out
of another tight spot. Michonne has always had
a way of coming out of nowhere to save the day,
just like she did with the formula for
Judith all the way back at the prison.
So it made sense that she would return
to play some part in the curtain-closer.
"And if it's me who doesn't make it,
you're going to have to lead the others
forward. Because you're the one who can."
Her presence in the finale isn't what upset fans
— people didn't like the way she was dressed.
Michonne has always looked great no matter who
she's fighting or how covered in blood she gets,
but her appearance in the Walking Dead finale had
fans scratching their heads. Michonne is spotless
and wearing intricate fighting leathers,
which led fans to wonder where the heck she
got her clothes. Many noted that Danai Gurira
looked more like Okoye, her Marvel character.
One fan commented,
As the only survivor from the main group
who's been around for a long while,
Rosita's death was hard to take. Unlike many
of the other main character deaths we've seen
in the series, hers wasn't bloody. She
gets bitten after falling into a group
of walkers with the newly recovered baby
Coco strapped to her chest. After a series
of badass maneuvers get the child to safety,
Rosita reveals she's been bitten on the back.
It's typical for The Walking Dead to handle a main
character death with a short-lived high marred by
tragedy, but fans just aren't buying the sequence
of events leading to Rosita's death. In fact,
Digital Spy called Rosita's end the dumbest death
in the entire series. A lot of fans agreed, and we
can't really blame them, because not much about it
makes sense. For one thing, the placement of her
bite seems off, considering that she's wearing
numerous layers of clothing. There's also the
fact that she's unable to make a jump that Eugene
made before her, even though she's leagues ahead
of him in physical ability. And, as one Redditor
pointed out, her actual passing was unconvincing.
The three previously announced Walking
Dead spin-offs, while good news for fans,
proved problematic for the finale of the original
series. First, knowing that most fan-favorite
characters couldn't be killed off drastically
lowered the stakes. To make matters worse, the
pending spin-offs influenced the finale in terms
of the story. For some fans, the send-off episode
was too much like a backdoor pilot for future
shows, rather than giving a solid, satisfying
ending to the original series. Fans were quick
to call the show out for this over on Reddit.
One user writes,
While it certainly makes sense to touch on where
the fan-favorite characters have been and are
heading in the finale, squeezing in intros
to three separate spin-offs is a bit much.
"We are endless."
Partially because of how much focus the finale
gave the upcoming spin-offs, the last episode of
the long-running series wasn't a true finale
at all. Even though the series was ending,
it was really just a new beginning. It's almost
as if production was afraid to give fans true
closure, in case they wouldn't want to
continue watching the future spin-offs.
Forbes senior contributor and
author Paul Tassi called a lot
of the creative decisions and some
of the more emotional scenes "cheap."
"I think of the dead all the time.
And about the living, who I lost."
According to Tassi, these scenes were there
to give the episode more of a finale feel,
but in truth, the episode lacked
any real shocks or twists.
"We have a lot to be proud of. Our
family. Our community. The future."
Tassi definitely isn't alone in this opinion.
To call something that spends half its
time talking up future storylines a
finale has been labeled a cop-out by a
lot of fans. There's an ongoing joke on
Reddit about how the series will never
really end. In the words of one user,
"You'll keep making it better."
"You will, too."
While another user added,
Another way the impending spin-offs affected
the finale is that the inclusion of so much
set-up made the rest of the episode feel
rushed. This isn't just a finale problem,
though. The entire Commonwealth plot that ended
the show wasn't as well put together as it should
have been. According to CBR, production was
forced to rush the Commonwealth plotline,
despite it being a huge undertaking. The
speedy run through the storyline did the
finale no favors. As Collider put it, the
episode felt "rushed" and "chaotic" at times.
"You disappeared hundreds of citizens. Led
the dead to our doorstep. You shot a child."
With so many survivors and
storylines coming together,
ticking every box was always
going to be tricky. In the end,
the finale contained too many leaps of logic.
An example of this is trying to nullify the
threat of zombies by blowing up a portion of the
Commonwealth. How is this a quick fix solution?
One thing that never seemed right about the
Commonwealth storyline is that we never really
see the place. The Commonwealth is supposed
to be made up of around 50,000 survivors. Yet,
we never see just how expansive and diverse
the community really is. The only plausible
explanation was that the creators were waiting
for the finale to unleash the full scale of
the Commonwealth and its population, which
never happened, leaving fans underwhelmed.
One Redditor writes,
Another user then claimed that the lack of numbers
in these big scenes was a hangover
from COVID-19 restrictions, writing,
Considering how much The Walking Dead
focuses on the themes of family and loyalty,
the survivors sure do leave their
kids behind a lot. It obviously
takes a village to raise a child in a
zombie apocalypse, we get that. However,
all the child abandonment becomes a
bit too much when parents go off on
their own missions, leaving their young
ones behind for the foreseeable future.
"Daryl?"
"Yeah."
"You deserve a happy ending, too."
The Grimes children don't see a
lot of their parents. While RJ and
Judith are lucky to have seasoned
survivors as parental figures,
it doesn't matter much when they're not
around. As one concerned Redditor put it:
Another user doubled down with,
For many fans on Reddit, the biggest problem
with the finale is a lack of closure.
As one commenter put it,
While another user added,
And a third piled on with an excellent point:
"We're together. Pieces of a whole that just keep
going for what we gave each
other. One unstoppable life."
While recognizing the finale's good moments,
Vulture's episode recap focuses on the lack
of solid closure, and comments on the oddity
of having the finale end with the promise of a
bright future while also preparing us to see the
spin-off survivors living through more struggles.
"I want to talk about the future. There's a lot
out there to find out about.
And I think it's time we did."
It's like the finale feigns closure,
but there's actually none given.